hi welcome to this week's episode of
cold fusion
last week we had a look at quibby the
netflix for mobile
it had a-list celebrities and two
billion dollars of funding but
failed in just six months today
we'll be turning to the ever brewing
story of huawei vs the united states
huawei currently the world's largest
smartphone manufacturer
was the first high-profile company to be
caught in the center of a feud
between two competing world powers the
united states of america
and china after the huawei crackdown
it was tick tock and wechat that came
under fire it's all extraordinary when
you think about it
so what are both sides of the story what
does this mean for huawei
who wins and who loses and how did this
all happen
in the first place and what's the latest
in the two years since the ban began
let's take a look you are watching toll
fusion tv
[Music]
so who are huawei we've already done an
episode on their massive size and
exactly what they do
but here's an outline for those who
missed it the company was founded in
1987 by ren thing fee
a member of the chinese people's
liberation army after his retirement
he would start the huawei company
initially focused on manufacturing phone
switches
huawei has since expanded its business
to include building telecommunications
networks
communication equipment and consumer
devices
from data storage to networks and
carrier software
to pcs vr wearables smart speakers
wi-fi routers usb modems and much more
they do a lot huawei has deployed its
products and services in more than 170
countries and has 21 foreign r d
institutes
internationally including countries like
the united states
canada and the uk huawei overtook
ericsson in 2012 to become the world's
largest telecommunications equipment
manufacturer
though to most people the company is
most known for their smartphones
as of q2 2020 they overtook samsung to
become the number one smartphone maker
selling 56 million units compared to
samsung's 54 million
in short they're a huge company but then
suddenly seemingly out of nowhere in
2018
they were banned by the us government
the company had an annual revenue of 120
billion us dollars last year
so this ban is a big deal
to understand why this happened we first
must understand
the bigger picture of the relations
between china and the us
until the 1970s china's economy was
under communist control by the
government
it was isolated and closed from other
economies
but throughout the 1970s they opened up
and in 2000
u.s president bill clinton signed the
u.s china relations act of 2000.
this agreement paved the way for china
to join the world trade organization
just a year later the idea was that
trade with china would benefit american
interests
this agreement
exchanges membership rights for china
and the wto
for economic opportunities for america
in china for american businesses
and american workers without the tariffs
and technology transfer requirements
and production and china requirements
and other requirements which have
limited our ability to benefit
from their market for too long almost
immediately chinese products flooded
into the u.s
and by the mid-2000s americans began to
notice that everything was made in china
the fact of the matter was that america
was starting to build a reliance on
china
anything from toys to laptops electronic
components
and appliances it was now much more cost
effective
and cheaper for american companies to
manufacture these goods in china and
sell them back to the united states
in 2006 china surpassed mexico as the
biggest trade partner to the united
states
after canada all of this trade with
america
the biggest consumers on the planet was
a huge boost to the chinese economy
in the second quarter of 2010 china
surpassed japan
as the world's second largest economy
in 2015 the chinese government unveiled
its plans to become the most
powerful economic empire by 2025.
in this plan they wanted their currency
the yuan
to be more powerful than the us dollar
one aspect of the plan was to pivot
private companies to shift their goals
towards the government's vision
the americans were now nervous the plan
was cited as a
quote real existential threat to u.s
technological leadership
end quote by an american think tank in
2018
a trade war between the united states of
america and
china soon exploded huawei being such a
big company
was quickly caught in the middle we are
being
taken advantage of okay and i don't like
it and i haven't liked it for many years
and i told that to president xi i said
how did this ever happen
we're down 507 billion dollars in trade
deficits
how did it happen and they told me
nobody ever complained there was never
anybody to talk to in the united states
so now that we know the driving factors
that made this situation reach a boiling
point
what was the actual ban
the united states accused huawei
products of spying for the chinese
government by using backdoors
it was claimed that this behavior would
be consistent with chinese laws that
required companies to cooperate with
state intelligence when needed
huawei emphatically denied these claims
and said
the chinese government never asked them
to have backdoors
and if asked in the future they would
refuse to comply
and mr ren you talk a lot about the
distance between huawei
and the chinese government but what
we've seen publicly
is senior officials in the government
talking
at times on huawei's behalf is that
useful to the company or do you find
that a distraction
first it's understandable that
government leaders would take pride in
the great companies of their country
second huawei is being stuck in an
extremely difficult
situation the us is launching intense
attacks against us if the u.s government
speaks ill of huawei
why couldn't the chinese government
speak in our favor
that creates a kind of balance in the
past
no one spoke up for us in 2018 the
united states passed a bill that stopped
the federal government from doing
business with huawei and other chinese
vendors due to security concerns
but even to date no solid evidence has
been brought forward to substantiate
these concerns
it could be a matter of the evidence
being withheld for national security
reasons
or the simple fact that the evidence
doesn't exist
right now this is anyone's guess despite
this
u.s companies had to stop using huawei
components in cell networks
and current systems must remove any
huawei components
america encouraged its allies to do the
same
things quickly escalated when the
chinese government threatened economic
retaliation
against countries that followed the us
ban in 2019
huawei filed a lawsuit against the u.s
government they cited that the ban was
unconstitutional because there was no
due process
or a chance of rebuttal from huawei the
ban
divided u.s allies politically australia
britain canada and new zealand
semi-banned huawei
but germany italy and much of europe
haven't
the german and british intelligence
agencies have pushed back on the us
allegations
stating that they've found no evidence
at first it seemed like the us was going
to look foolish
stephanie richard ceo of the mobile
network
orange stated that the claims of
backdoor spying were like the weapons of
mass destruction lie
told during the iraq war however in july
of 2020
the uk government backflipped and joined
the band for their 5g equipment
the reason this is an important moment
is because some will say this is a
moment where the uk
is asserting itself as an agile
independent political and economic power
others will say they're being a bit like
a pinball buffeted
between the big powers the us and china
which are engaged as frankly
in a full-scale economic cold war and
the uk
is caught in the crossfire india would
soon join following their northern
border conflict with china
france also recently stated that they
would favor european companies for their
5g
network in february of 2020
things escalated again the us department
of justice
charged huawei with racketeering and
conspiring to steal trade secrets
from six us companies there was some
precedent though
prior to this in 2014 huawei was accused
of various instances of intellectual
property theft
against parties such as cisco systems
and t-mobile us
a t-mobile lawsuit claimed that two
huawei usa employees
spied on a smartphone testing robot in a
lab on a visit to the lab
the employees photographed the robot and
stole one of its fingertips
huawei did admit wrongdoing by the two
huawei usa employees
and fired them
the most brutal part of the ban for
huawei was the restrictions on business
partners
essentially american companies must stop
supplying huawei with key components and
technologies
some of these entities include google
arm the taiwanese chipset maker tsmc
and mediatek so what does this mean
well google has to drop support for
huawei phones
no google maps gmail or any google apps
unfortunately for huawei no google apps
means that it's going to be very
unattractive to international buyers
how important do you think things like
google maps youtube all those
applications are
and they're very very important to be
able to have access to them on your
phone on the move
so if they didn't offer that it would
put me off using the phone completely
designs from the company arm are used in
huawei chips
and tsmc manufactures the chips
both are not us companies but the us has
pressured them to stop support
and stop manufacturing in september of
2020
huawei lost access to samsung and lg
suppliers because the display driver
ship had us technology
samsung ram is even off the table
it's estimated that huawei would lose 30
billion
in revenue in the next two years
following june 2019
[Music]
so what are they going to do in the
consumer market
huawei is going to create their own app
store and entire operating system
they actually already have and it's
called harmony os
it can run on anything from cars and
watches to smartphones and tvs
the software will be running on huawei
smartphones in december of 2020.
interestingly the software can share
resources from connected devices
for example displaying an image and
sound through a huawei tv
while using the camera and microphone of
a huawei phone
they also plan to attract developers by
bringing on board and promoting regional
app makers that would otherwise have to
fight to get market share in a flooded
market
harmony os is expected to run some
android apps
according to huawei their os is more
flexible than android and 60
faster they claim that one line of
harmony os
code can do a hundred lines of android
code i sat down with someone from huawei
to explain more about their new
operating system
the company also plans to grow out a
more robust network of partnerships
around the world
countries like japan and russia they're
also currently working out a deal with
qualcomm
though r d may be focused towards local
chinese chip manufacturing technology
despite the sanctions huawei has
launched the ninuan project
and has struck new chip supply deals
[Music]
okay so we're almost at the end of the
video but let's try and distill this
from both points of view
from america's point of view the general
view is that china has their fingertips
deep into huawei
and that having any huawei technology in
the nation is a big
risk to national security not to mention
the risk of having ips stolen
for america it's mainly a question of
trust
china's rise and the geopolitical
landscape of u.s china relations over
the past decade
may contribute to this view we
convinced many countries not to use
huawei
because we think it's an unsafe security
risk it's a big security risk we cannot
ensure the defense of the west
if our allies grow dependent on the east
for the benefit of a few corporations
you cannot sell the privacy
of the the people of your country down
the river
from huawei's point of view
i spoke to some people within huawei and
in their view
the real threat is the prison project
started in 2007 the prison project was
implemented by the us government to
collect
internet communications from companies
that now include
google facebook apple and microsoft
[Music]
huawei still asserts that there's been
no evidence of spying in over 170
countries
despite many the general view from
huawei is that it's being used as a pawn
to put pressure on china management in
huawei
claims that the us government persecutes
it because huawei's expansion can affect
american business interests
attorney general william barr has been
quoted as saying that the us needs to
ban huawei to maintain its tech
dominance
it's all a big ploy to keep the rising
china at bay
to them it all seems unfair and
unwarranted over the past century
which countries and companies have made
the us scare
the us hasn't been scared of anyone or
anything though
for such a powerful country to be scared
of a small
company like us some other countries are
saying
your products are so good that the us
government is scared
we won't test your products we'll buy
them directly
that's why some deep pocketed countries
with rich oil reserves
are buying from us they are buying our
products
in large quantities as the us government
is
advertising for us
in this there's going to be some
unintended consequences
as huawei breaks up from its u.s
suppliers the suppliers will lose money
in 2018 u.s companies earned around 11
billion dollars from huawei
in addition 5g systems may end up being
more expensive
and ripping out existing huawei systems
will cost money
in the uk this is set to cost 7 billion
pounds
in addition america may be seen as a
less secure place to do business than it
previously was
they had a virtually untarnished record
of free trade
in general any company that wanted to do
trade in america
could along with the more recent tick
tock ban
this pristine image is beginning to be
altered
even the risk fire foundation the
company that provides open source
software standards
for the chips that power smartphones has
moved from the us
to switzerland due to concerns about
stricter u.s regulation
this all isn't to mention further
escalation china
may retaliate by stopping american
companies from doing business with them
so in the end who wins so far
it seems like no one huawei will be
battered from this experience
but if they can achieve more robust
partnerships
they'll survive the us may have lost
some credibility with their european
allies
and may be perceived as a less stable
place for companies to invest
but back to huawei the main issue for
them is trust
and that's a question of human
psychology something that's becoming a
little unpredictable in modern times
though when you really do take this
entire situation as a whole
the real winner might be companies like
samsung they don't really have any tyres
to either side
and may see some benefit in the end only
time will tell
so what do you guys think which side do
you think is right
do you take huawei side and think the us
is scared of china rising
or do you take the us aside and think
that huawei is a front for china spying
let me know in the comment section below
in next week's episode
we'll be taking a look at apple's new m1
chip and what this means for the bigger
picture of the computing industry as a
whole
as it turns out this might not just be
more marketing hype from apple
and they could be on track to doing
something special
anyway that's about it from me thanks
for watching
don't forget to follow me on instagram
and twitter and as a side point
the standard cold fusion merch is still
available if you want to grab it
my name is dagogo and you've been
watching cold fusion
[Music]
cheers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you